moving on an update to a story that
we've covered on the show you may recall
representative john thompson he's the
minnesota state representative who was
pulled over for a traffic violation and
then immediately claimed that he was
racially profiled it was a lie of course
he wasn't
and they released the body cam footage
and nothing inappropriate happened in
the body cam footage
he committed a violation they pulled him
over the cop was nice and respectful
even as thompson was was belligerent and
angry and accusing him of racism
but it also turned out that thompson had
a suspended license a suspended out of
state license
and the license was suspended because it
wasn't paying childs for child support
payments so the guys are dead be dead
big surprise there but he doesn't have a
license in the state he represents
in fact as it has developed over the
last week or so it's not clear that he's
a resident at all
of the state he represents much less the
district
and he's been asked about this there was
a video of someone who saw him at the
airport
and was saying you know representative
are you a resident of your own district
and he wouldn't answer the question
and now this from fox 9
uh in st paul it says in searching for
state representative john thompson's
residency
fox 9 has uncovered four cases of
domestic violence
with allegations that thompson punched
hit and choked women
according to the police reports from
2003 to 2009 in some cases the assaults
happen in the presence of young children
questions about thompson's residency
were raised after he was stopped by
saint paul police on july 4 for not
having a front license plate
he accused them of racial profiling we
know about that okay the domestic
violence cases stretch back to 2003
in superior wisconsin when thompson was
arrested after he allegedly struck his
girlfriend in the face with an open and
closed fist
the woman's five-year-old daughter
witnessed the assault which happened in
a supermarket parking lot
thompson's girlfriend said she and her
child were homeless and declined to
cooperate
thompson apparently fled the scene in
that case thompson allegedly attacked
the same girlfriend nearly a year later
on
in august of 2004 at her apartment
police arrived
after a 9-1-1 hang-up call
she said that thompson choked her and
then
uh she said she ran out of the apartment
screaming but thompson grabbed her and
dragged her back to the apartment
she said she tried to escape through a
window she told police thompson became
angry when she dialed 911 from another
phone and began hitting her in the head
punching her in the face and then he
grabbed her and threw her into the
kitchen table
which broke all of her children
witnessed the assault
um and then in september what else do we
have here
in september 2009 saint paul police
officers responded to a call domestic
violence involving thompson and two
women
thompson and the women were fighting
about a cell phone he received from
another girlfriend that's unclear from
the report if it's the girlfriend from
the previous case
uh during that 2009 incident according
to reports
as the yelling escalated thompson pulled
out his penis in front of his girlfriend
and two young children and said i'm the
man you can all
and then he had some sexually explicit
things to say um and then he there was
another case of domestic violence as
well so
this is someone allegedly involved in
allegedly
a serial domestic abuser who's also
who's also
exposed himself to children
we know that part of it the left has no
problem with that whatsoever
um and they really don't have a problem
with the domestic violence either
especially when it comes to these blm
martyrs
it it is it is really incredible how
consistent this is
you know i always point this out and i'm
continually pointing it out because it
keeps happening
these blm martyrs and john thompson
tried to be
he wants to be one of them tried to
martyr himself
um almost always it turns out that these
are
violent abusers of women and yet again
it's the same thing here
and no big surprise actually because
here's
john thompson before he was elected this
was back in 2020
before he was elected standing outside
of a white family's house where kids are
present
screaming at them for having a blue
lives matter sign in their yard
let's listen to that i'm a black man
he is terrorized by this man right here
we are terrorized by the grand wizard
y'all got the grand wizard living in
your
neighborhood oh the clan exists in hugo
minnesota
and it's right here don't run now don't
run
now racist white people i'm here oh yeah
we pull up
[Music]
yeah he's being terrorized by that the
family those women it's
all women out there including kids
he's terrorized by them because of what
a sign they have in the yard
and after that incident which which uh
went viral at least locally
he was elected and not in spite of that
these voters elected him because of that
they want these
these scumbag pieces of garbage
representing them that's what they want
and they get exactly this is what you
get when you when you elect people like
this
this is exactly what you get voters in
his district
you absolute morons
you're you are bad people also for
electing someone like that
that is that is a moral failing to elect
someone like that
you elected because you like the way he
screamed at white people
what other what other qualifications did
he bring to the table he's not even a
resident of your district
he doesn't even live with you
but he really liked how he uh you know
how he he showed those white girls
what's what
this is not we got to stop acting like
voters are
you know innocent helpless victims you
you went to the polls and voted for this
guy
you're not much better than him
just this guy's a liar a fraud an abuser
a
horrible scumbag garbage person
and uh yeah you know elect him to
represent you well he represents you
you want him to represent you and so he
does he's garbage
i don't know if the shoe fits you wanted
him representing you
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content